nach dem abpfiff des wm finales zwischen
frankreich und kroatien gab es trauer
aber auch freude über den vize
weltmeistertitel in zagreb immerhin war
es das erste mal dass kroatien ein
finale der fußball weltmeisterschaft
erreicht hat grund genug für die fans in
der kroatischen hauptstadt zufrieden zu
sein auch wenn ihr team in moskau zuvor
4 zu 2 gegen frankreich verloren hatte
es war wirklich schwer anzuschauen ich
musste weinen aber allein die tatsache
dass sie es ins finale geschafft haben
ist als wären wir weltmeister
und um ehrlich zu sein die ersten zwei
spiele von kroatien waren für mich viel
schwieriger anzuschauen
es war ein sehr gutes spiel und ein
tollpatschiger sieg für die franzosen
wir haben 16 mal besser gespielt aber
wir haben kein glück die anderen
hingegen umso mehr
und die kroaten weltweit fieberten mit
hier bilder aus münchen von sonntagabend
wo hunderte fans zusammenkamen um ihr
team anzufeuern
ähnliche impressionen dann auch aus dem
australischen sydney also es ist hart
aber wir sind auch glücklich kein
anderes team hätte so gespielt wie wir
sie haben es einfach nicht gepackt aber
sie haben einfach alles gegeben nun wir
haben geschichte geschrieben denn
vielleicht klappt es erst in 20 oder 30
jahren wieder ich bin sehr stolz auf das
was kroatien erreicht hat
der finaleinzug also unterm strich ein
großer aber auch völlig verdienter
erfolg für kroatien
denn schließlich hatten sie vorher teams
wie argentinien gastgeber russland und
england geschlagen die nächste
weltmeisterschaft findet übrigens ende
2022 in katar statt
[Applaus]